Wanted to introduce you to some very special.
This is Tana. And Tana is amazing nutritionist and dear friend
who helped us get no in your hands.
So I wanted her to come to the farm and just chat.
Charlie taste so good, don't you think?
Taste so good. It is really good.
And we are both chocolate people,
but there is something about the vanilla that if you haven't tried it,
it's rich and it's got like,
a depth to it. Protein has hemp in it.
Hemp protein. And at one of the tastings,
Tanner was like, it feels like the.
The flavor is off. You know,
hemp is one of a superior plant protein.
There's so many benefits for it,
but it also can kind of taste earthy.
So in the taste testing, they put the hemp hole,
which is kind of the outside of the hemp seed,
and it didn't quite taste as rich as we wanted it to.
The. The idea was to quickly run and go grab some hemp heart,
which is the white internal part,
the richer part of the hemp.
We swapped out the hemp whole powder and put in the hemp heart powder,
and then all of a sudden, it got this yummy, rich,
really good creamy flavor.
So that's why we love it, because there's no emulsifiers,
and emulsifiers are put into makeup.
Protein powder, creamy,
but it's a inferior way that actually can kind of ruin your gut health.
So The fact that we were able to do it with hemp is so awesome
because there's no emulsifiers,
and you still get this yummy,
creamy protein powder. Blossom is awesome
because it actually is a massive quantity of peptides and nutrients,
and those are the things that are missing from our diet
that make your gut really, really,
really fortified. Um,
colostrums
lately to also been shown to help with so many health concerns like,
um, allergies and gut health and mental clarity.
The main purpose of colostrum
is to really fortify your internal gut microbiome.
It's not a probiotic, so I don't
people that get confused that it's got a probiotic
actually living in it, but it is a form of a gut fortifier,
so colostrum is so awesome.
Collagen peptides, which are so good.
Collagen is, like,
also an incredible form of a protein
because it has the amino acids
that help strengthen bones and ligaments.
Are really good for your skin and for your hair.
Collagen is. Yeah,
look at your hair. Well,
and yours is, too.
I mean, it's so great because it kind of is sneaky.
It's hard to find you. It's the best to get it from a bovine source.
So collagen.
I feel like I take collagen every single day without fail,
because sure enough, there's some kind of fortification.
As we get old,
our bones and our ligaments and all those things kinda start to decay.
So this is such a great Way to fortify em
100% grass fed way too. And I love it
because in the grass fed way,
there is a component called CLA,
which again, probably too nerdy,
we don't need to go in there.
But why we love that is because when they're grass fed,
they're getting all of the rich nutrients that are in the grass.
Like think of a green blade of grass,
it's got polyphenols, it's got the color,
it's grown by the light,
has all the rich sources of vitamins and minerals.
So when the cows eat that,
then you know that the way the cow is producing
also has all of those properties in it.
Simplest way to put it. Next up is the hemp protein,
which we already talked about in your inulin fiber.
Fiber. You guys,
this is like one of the coolest things about this protein
is a lot of protein powders don't have fiber in it.
We need about 30 to 35 grams of fiber every single day
just to really help our our bodies function.
Well, like,
fiber is the missing ingredient in most people's diet.
And so in order to be able to get it,
it comes in little quantities,
like twos and three. So it can be tricky,
but it does add up. And so it was so awesome.
We put in an inulin fiber in the protein powder,
and the inulin fiber acts as a prebiotic,
so it actually feeds the good bacteria.
That's In your gut already.
So there's a bonus. You get the three grams of fiber and the gut boost.
Sometimes people get really bloated
when they use a lot of whey protein.
Is because it has all these other additives
and fillers and natural flavors,
and sometimes the ways also inferior.
So this was really fun to put together,
because you gotta use the best of the best.
And so you don't feel bloated,
you don't feel that kinda like achy gut feeling.
Cause it's just so rich with nutrients in it.
And it really did will boost your
your gut microbiome. It will help your muscle mass increase.
It just helps fortify your whole body.
Of the cute kids laughing in the background.
They're so cute over there.
Okay, so monk fruit,
I think its real ancient name is like Louhan or something like that.
But it's actually been around for thousands of years.
It's a leaf you take and you condense it down
and it naturally sweet. In fact,
that's how they've been sweetening tea in Asia
for thousands and thousands of years.
And there's no high carb load,
there's no artificial flavors of any kind.
It actually is just a leaf that they've taken down and condensed.
That has a natural sweetness to it.
So it's the best way to sweeten your food.
I actually sometimes even will bake with it.
But I love monk fruit. Devia is also a leaf.
In fact, I actually reduced my Own stevia this summer.
I picked the leaves. You know who I got it from was Cynthia.
Cynthia gave me her stevia leaves,
so I boiled them down and then reduced them over the pot,
and it literally is so good.
So there are clean sources of stevia
that you can get and put in protein powder.
So that's why we're not afraid of steam.
Put over pot and reduced it.
And I have a little dropper of my own homemade stevia.
So anyways,
it really. There are clean ways?
Yes. Most often you buy it package,
and it's got some other additives in it.
And some of those additives have been known to cause cancer
and all sorts of things, which. Yes,
we do not wanna go anywhere near that.
No. But there are clean forms of Stevie that you can find and use
that are so great. So we have creamy chocolate.
Hmm. Vanilla bean,
which has the real vanilla.
Oh, that's what makes it so good.
And we have maple cinnamon,
your signature flavor. Signature flavor is so good.
It is so good. I think it's a farm signature flavor. Yeah.
Drinking it for five years,
so. Oh,
my gosh, it's so yummy.
And someone made pancakes out of it.
I tried that. It is so good.
It was delicious. I've mixed it with the pancakes,
and it's good by itself. This protein powder,
it's so yummy when you mix it with the milk.
And I've even Done. Almond milk. Yeah.
And there is something to it
that doesn't feel like it's your typical protein.
Yeah, so true.
Yeah. Yeah,
that was the test for me. I was like,
okay, it's good in milk.
Let's just try with water.
It was good with water. So good.
I warmed up my chocolate one.
I actually had hot water and a little splash of almond milk.
It's even better, actually warm the chocolate one.
So, yeah,
they're all yummy. Okay,
so talk a tiny bit about maple cinnamon and.
Oh, yeah,
the late harvest maple sugar.
Yes, the.
The. You'll notice on the package,
the late harvest maple syrup.
Maple sugar. Sugar, um,
is kept later on in the season because it retains a lot more nutrients.
So when you pull it a little bit too soon,
it's still yummy and has that great flavor.
But when you keep it and don't harvest it until later,
there's a lot more benefits that come with a little bit less carb,
reduced reduction, and it's a little bit sweeter.
It's the flavor that changes,
so you get more bang for your buck.
So the extra. The extra sugar grams that you see on the maple cinnamon
come from the actual maple sweetener.
It's not. Are from the flavor.
It's not like we've added extra sugar to make the flavor more sugary.
Yeah. Sweeter.
But because this protein has that 3 grams of fiber in it,
you can subtract some of the Carb load.
And the fiber will actually kind of act as,
like, a net,
and it will catch and reduce your blood sugar levels or your carb load.
So you don't even actually spike your insulin
because of the fiber that's in there.
Which is another reason why I love that we got to put the fiber in,
so you don't have to stress about that extra added sugar
because it mostly just comes from the maple.
Cinnamon is so great. Cinnamon is actually a metabolism booster.
It's kind of a fat burner.
So you have the cinnamon with the maple and then the fiber.
You've got a perfect combination with lots of flavor,
so it's really good. Mmm.
Yeah, I know.
I love. So fun.
Gorgeous view over here. Oh, yeah,
this is our. This is our view.
I know. And the kids.
It's like the perfect day today.
We got kids jumping on the tramp.
I know. So, anyways,
Hope. Hannah,
thanks for coming. Hopefully we covered all. Yeah.
More things to come. This is so fun.